we've got two tables over here this
first table tells us that for any given
value of x what is the value of B to the
X so for example if we look right over
here with X is one point five eight five
B to the one point five eight five is
three so this this is telling us that B
to the one point five eight five is
equal to three similarly similarly I can
never say that it's telling us that B to
the two point three two two is five be
the two point eight oh seven to seven B
to the two point one six nine is nine
now this table over here is telling us
for any given value of y what is going
to be log base B of Y so this tells us
that log base B of A is zero log base B
of 2 is one log base B of 2 C is one
point five eight five log base B of 10 D
so this is literally this is telling us
that log base B of 10 D is equal to two
point three to two that's what this last
column tells us now what I challenge you
to do is pause this video and using just
the information here and you don't need
a calculator in fact you can't use a
calculator I forbid you try to figure
out try to figure out what a B C and D
are just using your powers of reasoning
no calculator involved just use your
powers of reasoning can you figure out
what a B C and D are so I'm assuming
you've given a go at it so let's see
what we can do from this so here we have
just a bunch of numbers we we need to
figure out what B is so and these are
all kind of you know B to the 1.58 five
power is three I don't really know what
to make sense of this stuff here maybe
maybe this table will help us
so this first let me do this in
different colors this first column right
over here tells us that log base B of a
so now Y is equal to a that that is
equal to zero now this is an equivalent
statement to saying that B to the a
power
is equal to
is a sign not be to the a power this is
an equivalence a statement to saying be
to the zero power to the zero power is
equal to a this is saying what exponent
do I need to raise B to to get a well
you raise it to the zero power this is
saying B to the zero power is equal to a
now what is anything to the 0 power
assuming that it's not zero if we're
assuming that we're dealing with that B
is not zero if we're assuming that B is
not zero then so we're going to assume
that and we can't assume and I think
that's a safe assumption because we're
raising beat all of these other powers
we're getting a nonzero value so since
we know that B is not zero anything that
the zero power is going to be one so
this tells us that a is equal to one so
that's we got one figured out a is equal
to one now let's look now let's look at
this next piece of information right
over here what does that tell us that
tells us that log base B of 2 of 2 is
equal to 1 this is a equivalent to
saying the power that I need to raise B
to to get to 2 is 1 or if I want to
write an exponential form I could write
this is saying that B to the first power
is equal to 2 so I'm raising something
to the first power and I'm getting 2
what is this thing well that means that
B must be 2 2 to the first power is 2 so
b is equal B is B is equal to 2 B to the
first power is equal to you could say B
to the first is equal to 2 to the first
that's also equal to 2 so B must be
equal to 2 so we've been able to figure
that out so this is a 2 right over here
it actually makes sense two to the one
point five eight five power that yeah
that feels right that that's about three
now let's see what else we can do let's
see if we can figure out C so let's look
at this column let's see what this
column is telling us that column we
could read it as log base B now our Y is
2 C log base B of 2 C is equal to one
point five eight five or we could read
this
as be if we write an exponential form B
to the 1.58 5 is equal to 2c now what's
B to the one point five eight five well
they tell us right over here that B to
the one point five eight five is three
is three so this right over here is
equal to three so we get to C is equal
to three or divide both sides by two we
would get C is equal to one point five
this is working out pretty well and now
we have this last column which I will
circle in purple and we can re we can
write this as log base B of ten D of 10
D is equal to two point three to two so
this is saying the power I need to raise
B to to get to ten D is two point three
to two or in exponential form B to the 2
point 3 to 2 is equal to 10 D now what
is B to the two point three to two well
they tell us over here B B to the 2
point 3 to 2 is 5 so this is equal to 5
so we could write 10 D is equal to 5 or
divide both sides by 10 D is equal to
0.5 and we're done we were able to
figure out what a B and C a B C and D
are without the use of a calculator